welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
falcon in the winter soldier episode 4
in which john walker avenges
battlestar's death with a punch steve
rogers bold
he's already dead i'm gonna break down
this episode shot by shot for where
everything you might have missed because
there's a lot of cool details in this
okay we opened in wakanda
six years ago now this series is set six
months
after end game roughly april 2024 six
years prior to that would be
april 2018 which would be just a few
weeks before thanos's forces arrived and
t'challa gave bucky his new vibranium
arm so
bucky really had no time to enjoy his
freedom before being dragged back into
battle which is why he's still not
really okay in this series
the dora melange io does this far
outside the city past a waterfall that
could be part of the warrior falls
waterways all to keep bucky away from
the crowded areas of the country and i o
repeats the russian hydro winter soldier
activation code referenced by zemo last
episode and appearing in every episode's
closing credits
actually this episode bioactress
florence kusumba appears right beside it
her name translating from wakandan
signaling her crucial role in helping
bucky overcome these haunting words now
ever since civil war fans have looked
into these words for a deeper
metaphorical meaning like homecoming
could be for spider-man homecoming or
freight car could be the train car that
bucky fell from though the writers of
that movie said that they chose those
words because they sounded melodic and
menacing in russian but here we do get a
new interesting meaning with the words
because some of them trigger specific
memories for bucky furnace brings up the
hydra kernel with the red book and when
zemo used that same book to activate
bucky and berlin
all while bucky's blood boils and rage
over that brainwashing
we see a flashback on bucky's attack on
howard and maria stark specifically when
he choked maria and then the word benign
comes in with bucky trying to claw out
tony's arc reactor in the civil war
fight right before tony blast off his
arm
both men tried to render each other
benign and neutralize their primary
weapons but the shift comes in with the
word homecoming which shows the briefest
flash of bucky's final fight in captain
america winter soldier when steve told
him
because i'm with you to the end of the
line that was the moment steve broke
through to his old buddy and began the
long road to bringing him home
and with that the winter soldier music
that has wailed through this struggle
[Music]
give it fades away giving away to just
some simple
piano chords
an ao tells him you are free and bucky
can't even believe it he has to look up
at her to make sure she just said that
and she repeats
[Music]
and only then can this man finally
breathe freely
one of my favorite scenes in the mcu
ever but before i continue thanks to
today's sponsor
afk arena in fk arena players build and
level up a team of heroes from seven
different factions and go to battle
using different battle strategies
the way you pair the heroes from
different factions impacts the game
strategy and gives you more gameplay
options there's a ton to do in this game
and the animation is in a cool fantasy
style
afk has the classic rpg elements but
doesn't require an enormous time
investment this isn't like getting a new
part-time job
building your team is like assembling a
group of buddies for an adventure but
your buddies have broadswords and shoot
fireballs like my imaginary friends do
and thanks to afk arena you can get a
chance to build your own dream team
in afk arena you can collect from over
100 heroes for free
including brutus who i like because he
looks like beast from beauty and the
beast but with a giant sword
nomura is some kind of half goat
character but
she's a support champion and let's be
honest we can all use some more support
from our friends
this is my dream team what's yours get
yourself some of these awesome heroes by
downloading and playing
afk arena between april 6th and may 5th
every player gets 100 summons and one
special gift code this pretty crazy
bonus is unprecedented so don't miss a
chance
build your dream team with 103 summons
and support new rockstars by clicking on
the link in the description to download
afk arena but back in latvia io says
the winter soldier programming was
removed from the laker rotten firm
using the analogy of shaving matted fur
from a feral canine reflecting their
nickname for bucky as the white wolf
they mentioned shuri and king tachaka
and bucky says in wakandan
yeah but he can speak wakandan add that
to the list of english russian romanian
and japanese and here by calling zemo a
means to an end he echoes zemo's own
machiavellian view where the ends
justify the means and loyalty to
tactical allies is not
permanent back inside zemo questions the
very notion of super soldiers that
warped
aspiration that led to nazis to ultron
to the avengers hey those are our
friends you're talking about the
avengers
not the knots yeah i love how bucky had
to clear that up but then zemo says
this the desire to become a superhuman
cannot be separated from supremacist
ideals yeah
in truth the history of american
superhero comics from the 1930s
superman by jerry siegel and joe
schuster captain america by joe simon
and jack kirby
were attempts to reframe the idea of a
superman with american virtues and
patriotic colors
as a response to nazi propaganda of
white supremacy
inspired by philosophers like friedrich
nietzsche's concept of the
ubermensch in german superman the belief
that some men can just be superior
enough that they're unbound by
the laws of society which is essentially
how johann schmidt red skull saw himself
and as they discussed this whole nazi
history and the american responses
created by jewish writers
zemo's window is segmented in the shapes
of the star of david but the important
words that zemo says
are the desire to become a superhuman
sam doesn't want the serum bucky didn't
want it steve rogers arguably didn't
really know what it was
but john walker hmm he wants it that is
the problem
now bucky says the serum never corrupted
steve touche
but there has never been another steve
rogers has there
now sam might just be conceding that
steve was surely one of a kind but
sam did meet a second steve the old
steve who gave him that shield after
previous steve disappeared in the past
now it's still unclear how much society
knows about old cap like he wasn't
mentioned in the museum exhibit recap of
the in-game events and torres thinks cap
is living on the moon whatever's going
on here sam knows more than he is
telling us about that old guy
zemo pulls out some turkish delights
turkish delight
[Music]
irresistible he uses these later to
bribe the refugee kids for info similar
to the white witch using turkish
delights on edmond and the lion the
witch and the wardrobe by the way if you
have not had a turkish delight trust me
they are very
resistible the flag smashers react to
the news of carly's terrorism last
episode
the grc formally began drafting
legislation known as the patch act which
would seek to restore traditional border
regulations
and fast track the return to normalcy
something is off about this scene this
weird sounding voiceover that's loud
enough to be heard by everyone but just
coming off of
whose phone there's this overhead shot
of carly standing far
away from everyone else and then cut to
an immediate close-up where she's just
sitting
right among them and then this insert of
a phone with just a generic news b-roll
no
news outlet logo yeah like last episode
i think this is another flag smasher
scene that just looks super re-edited
which i theorize could be due
to a virus-related subplot with the flag
smashers that had to be removed
actually later in the episode there is a
similar moment with carly's big line
we separate them and then we kill
captain america
sure sure it's not unusual to show
reaction shots while other people are
talking that's basic editing especially
for nico who grew up as a cap fan and
will soon die ironically by the capped
shield but to just use full
coverage for this big dramatic line
suggests that something might have been
reworked in this scene it's interesting
how they've been avoiding mentioning
oh i don't know how mamadonia died which
apparently last episode according to dr
nega was tuberculosis but that was
clearly an awkwardly jammed in adr line
in that scene
so yeah i have a video coming out soon
explaining exactly what was probably
changed and what this mystery storyline
probably was
zemo sings baba black sheep to the kids
and then he tells them
turkish delight
was always my son's favorite zemo lost
his family in the battle of sokovia and
similarly bucky's friend mr nakajima
recalled his son's favorite dessert
these avengers keep getting people's
sons killed now bucky's pissed at zemo
for playing coy and sam says
he's just gonna extort you into that
stupid head tilt thing i love how
zemo pun tilts his head right after that
now sam calls sharon carter over in
madrapore and the graffiti behind her
shows the cheshire cat from alice in
wonderland this is all art by
jisor that is an actual instagram handle
for a real atlanta artist
and this was all shot in atlanta's krog
street tunnel sharon tells them
power broker went ape when he heard
about nagel he wants the serum back
you killed the golden goose magikor
poor's about to get real nasty
so yeah sharon carter is not herself the
power broker but she might be working
for him like notice how she gives nods
to each of these guards she's involved
in some crime
organization behind her personal art
dealings which uh by the way
we crunched the numbers there all that
art would add up to a value of
over half a billion dollars she's not
just one person she's part of a network
actually in the past week marvel
unveiled this awesome promo website
explorematripor.com with wanted posters
for characters with references to the
comic issues they first appeared
actually previously on the site you
could see ships with names like mystique
and
references to shang chi reportedly but
then those images were quickly taken
down i don't know if this shang chi
report is legit it does support my
theory that the power broker could be
connected to the mandarin or his
organization the ten rings
they hide the sierra at the grave of
niko's grandfather lucas kovacic
who served with allied forces in world
war ii making nico grow up a huge fan of
captain america
and making it tragically ironic that cap
shield is what ends his life
carly says that shield is a monument to
a bygone era a reminder of all the
people history just left out
if anything that shield should be
destroyed you know sam suggested the
same thing last episode maybe i
shouldn't have put it in a museum maybe
i should have destroyed it
with him echoing a lot of flag smasher
talking points this episode i think it's
likely that these two are going to
partner up
now when walker and hodgkin show up they
get the attention of some nearby
onlookers who take pictures
a reminder that everything walker says
and does in public will
be recorded notice how walker has not
shaved
and that scruff just grows more and more
until it fills in the final scene
so this guy is going rogue and he is
unhinged
wyatt russell does such a good job this
episode expressing it with all these
subtle physical
tics like when he touches his forehead
again and again as if suffering from a
chronic migraine
and then in the scene where the girl
leads him to the funeral watch walker in
the background right before we cut to a
new scene
he looks down and jerks his head to the
side right before the cut
now at the funeral there are a lot of
child actors and you know what that
means a lot of kids looking creepily
into the camera lens
roll the clip i was alone
[Music]
like a lot of you here mommy don't save
me actually turkish delight girl did it
earlier excuse me
carly holds donya's hamsa pendant a
symbol of spiritual significance to many
religions normally it has an
eye but here it has a world showing the
origin of the flag
logo but then a scramble and zemo
crushes
the serum vials actually director kari
skoglyn cuts in from below
angles of that blue serum spilling
everywhere swapping in transparent
plexiglass for the surface
it's a cool visual trick that's used a
lot in breaking bad to show the blue
meth from below
but walker finds the last unbroken vial
[Applause]
ah that creepy head tilt and that music
as if walker's got his own super soldier
whale
now walker threatens sam to turn zemo
over how do you want the rest of this
conversation to go sam huh
yeah should i put down a shield make it
fair
yeah look at hoskin's side eye there
like is going to get me
killed and then when he sets down the
shield and arises hidden in the
background no one saw this sneaky sneaky
door melanche
walker insults them by calling their
vibranium spears pointy sticks
and questioning their jurisdiction as if
he has any the dora milaji have
jurisdiction wherever the dora milari
find
themselves to be i love this fight
there's lots of amazing teamwork among
the dorm lager first io knocks walker
into the spear that was already thrown
by the first one
and then io passes that first one her
spear and pulling out the other one's
wedge spear
trading spears oh by the way trading
spears is also what britney's dad has
been doing with the courts her money is
hers hashtag free britney now when sam
intervenes the vibranium spear mixes
with the sound of a
panther growl and then walker gets
pinned with his shield and io
deactivates bucky's vibranium arm by
hitting these pressure points
a little shout out to bost the wakandan
panther deity
and when bucky pops it back on it emits
a purple glow
the color shuri's black panther tech
glows when it transmits kinetic energy
also there's a bit of a hexagonal
pattern there like everything in shuri's
lab
it's not mephisto shut up and then bucky
swings his arm around and reload his arm
just like he did in captain america
winter soldier adorama lager
kick flips the shield to her arm caps
big move from the elevator and captain
america winter soldier and a move
taskmaster will do in black widow
could taskmaster be a wakandan no maybe
i just think you can do this if you
really know your way around vibranium
and walker wallows in defeat they
weren't even super soldier
[Music]
composer henry jackman brings back the
music from civil war
during cap and tony's final fight sam
says zima pulled in el chapo referencing
the mexican crime boss who tunneled out
of prison via a bathroom escape hatch
and hoskins says about the serum power
just makes a person
more themselves right echoing the words
of dr erskine who told steve rogers that
the serum amplifies whatever character
traits that the person has inside and
after going home to change into sam's
falcon suit and bucky's fighting leather
they confront carly who says
that she doesn't want to kill them
because you're not hiding behind a
shield and then moments later
walker enters hiding behind his shield
gun
out it's actually similar to steve's
entrance with the howling commandos in
the first cap film now when sharon calls
notice she has a bloody lip with scars
on her knuckles now i figured these were
from her scuffle in the shipyard last
episode but it didn't look like she had
that
lip in the scene earlier she did say
magic board was about to get nasty
she might have had to endure the power
broker's wrath for letting nagel get
killed
walker wedges the shield in the wall
still adjusting to his new super
soldier's strength now that he's juiced
up
notice how he twitches this guy is
losing control over his own body
walker growls what's with all the knives
maybe a callback to howard stark's line
the first cap film
hydra's not going to attack you with a
pocket knife walker flings a knife
off his shield nearly killing bucky who
grabs it midair
similar to walker's careless shield
tosses near bucky said in episode two
but bucky uses this knife to do
his cool little knife flip move that he
also didn't win her soldier meanwhile
hoskins cuts himself free from a room
with dripping shower heads of doom just
in time to save walker from carly but he
gets punched into a column killing him
ugh now in the comics the killing of
walker's parents by the watch dogs
causes his mental break
but here it is the loss of his best
friend and you can see a bit of blood
trickles from above his ear as if he's
had some kind of head wound maybe
even concussed walker jumps through the
window to the street below
a reversal of cap's big jump up through
the window in civil war
reflecting walker's moral descent and
nico pleads for his life but walker
brings that shield down
into the guy's chest the same move cap
did to finish the fight against
iron man and civil war but whereas cap
delivered just one blow to tony's chest
to de-power his armor
and spare tony's life walker smashes it
into nico's chest
again and again true savage overkill
and it is heartbreaking to see nico a
childhood cat fan
now screaming in terror framed with this
same symbol
bearing it down on him until the whole
thing eclipses his face in the frame
and that is the last time we see nico's
face when he is alive now
this is taking place in riga latvia
actually that statue faced with the
three stars in the credits every episode
that's of the freedom monument in the
city of riga
however they didn't shoot this scene in
latvia they shot it in prague
that nearby statue is that of yosef
youngman czech poet linguist who
actually created the modern czech
language
but nico dies on a nearby platform that
was constructed as a set piece and it
reads god bless latvia which is probably
built so they wouldn't piss off local
proc city officials by beating a dude to
death on a beloved monument
which yeah this is horrific this episode
is titled the whole world is watching
a chant that we have heard with many blm
protests in the past year
and walker getting recorded is a
definite nod to the countless recordings
of police brutality
last episode actually opened with walker
telling police not to give their suspect
a second to breathe
and these recordings of walker are
everything because we know from cap's
exhibit that street level imagery can
get immortalized that photo of him using
the car door as a shield in his exhibit
was actually if you go back to that
first cap film snapped by a photographer
in the background like
all these photographers now and it is
these onlookers whose walkers focus goes
to not even aware of what they're
staring at
until we end on the final shocking
reveal the captain america shield
covered in blood honestly more blood
than mcu titles really ever typically
show
but the even scarier hidden detail in
the shot look at walker's other hand it
continues to twitch as we cut to black
his
inner demons are now fully in control
hey by the way this is our new anarchy
assembled shirt it's available at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you've been following our weekly
fitness series fitness origins
the daily workouts that tommy and i have
been doing can actually be found on the
epic hero fitness youtube channel so
that
you can join us in this journey if you
like and you can check out other bts
footage that we'll be posting there so
yeah go over subscribe to the epic hero
fitness youtube channel follow me on
instagram and twitter ea boss follow the
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube for breakdowns
of everything marvel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you